görlitz hinterlassenschaft ein
bilderschatz von ungeklärter provenienz
der jetzt den anstoß liefert den
schleier des kollektiven vergessens und
verdrängens zu lüften und er nicht nur
ein mediales beben ausgelöst hat sondern
auch immensen politischen druck
konfrontiert wird mit kunst und löst die
frage gibt über restriktionen dann hat
natürlich deutschland das problem schon
so sagen und dann ist entsprechend
konnte wurde eine internationale task
force zur erklärung oder eingesetzt die
gelder für die nachverfolgung verdoppelt
welche kunstwerke auf unrechtmäßigen weg
in die sammlung gelangt sind ist nicht
leicht zu
bei 1200 bildern trafen bislang erst
sechs rückgabeforderungen 1
auch das hat uns cornelius kolig
hinterlassen
das staunen dass ein einzelner mann eine
kunstsammlung von unermesslichem wert
jahrzehntelang unbemerkt in einer
münchner mietwohnung und in einem
häuschen in salzburg aufbewahrt hatte
sie sind absolute spezialisten also den
awo natürlich wächst
50 jahre deine bilder also mit dem erbe
mit dem sehr schwierigen herbe würde ich
mal sagen hat müsse ungarn und die
lösung für sich gefunden hat dass er
einfach der leiche mit einer bilder lebt
und und zuschnitt machten die glaubten
zu heiß darauf
ich glaube dass ich natürlich bis wo
halt eine sensation ausgelöst hat oder
so dass das bild von dem einsamen mit
einer fliege bilder anfangs wehrte sich
cornelius college gegen
rückgabeforderungen die umstände unter
denen sein vater der kunsthändler
hildebrand ballett die bilder im dritten
reich erworben hatte wollte er gar nicht
so genau kennen
doch im verlauf der debatte willigte er
ein bilder bei denen sich der raubkunst
verdacht erhärten ließ an die
rechtmäßigen eigentümer zurückzugeben
und ging damit weiter als viele museen
und privatsammlungen für die er nun
gewissermaßen als moralisches vorbild
dasteht
welche auswirkungen hat die causa geht
nun auf den umgang mit raubkunst die
herkunfts forscher wünschen sich mehr
transparenz bei der aktenlage und mehr
kooperation der kunstsammler gemäß der
deutschen justiz sollte gold seine
sammlung zurückgehalten wenn er die
herkunft der werke abklären müsse doch
dazu kam es nicht mehr
goldstar ohne seine geliebten bilder mit
der besitz zu haben
seine sammlung so beschloss er
testamentarisch sollte nicht in
deutschland bleiben
er vermachte sie völlig unerwartet im
kunstmuseum bern
ich komme ich natürlich kräuter ich bin
aber auf erschrocken freut wenn das
ganze bedeuten die sammlung ist uns ganz
alten ist das kunstmuseum wirklich
sommerlich schenkt über und nicht bloß
als lieblose form von oder schriftlich
sondern mir mit der sammlung wirklich
wie mir mit ihrer umgehend zum anderen
gibt es sehr viele offene fragen
hier sind die medien des langen
diskutiert wurde
wir übernehmen verantwortung dass die
fall rasch speditiv und ethisch korrekt
gelöst werden eine große aufgabe für
eine große sache